foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agree to tell each other over
and
you forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones update
video in this new video I want to
discuss what happened when Mr Harrington
sat down for an interview at Jimmy
Fallon's late night show as you all know
HBO and Kit Harington have been working
on a new series set after the events of
Game of Thrones the Jon Snow show will
focus on his life after he was sent
north of the wall at the end of the
final season of The Original Series so
far HBO hasn't made any official
announcements regarding the Jon Snow
series but a lot of information has
already been confirmed by George RR
Martin himself we already know they have
been working on this show since Game of
Thrones ended over three years ago as of
right now HBO and Mr Harrington have
done a great job at guarding their
secrets about the show all of the
sensitive information regarding this
Show's story has remained hidden and I
know how you can do the exact same thing
whenever you're online all you have to
do is jump on this amazing new offer
while you still can I'd like to thank
the sponsor of today's video private
internet access VPN I personally have
used a VPN for years and I use it
anytime I'm on the internet there are so
many benefits to using a VPN service not
only does it guard your information in
identity by putting a virtual barrier
between you and anyone trying to hack
you but it also opens up access to
Internet and streaming services that are
locked in your region if there is a show
on Netflix you want to stream or a
YouTube video unavailable to your region
you can go in and select which country
you want to appear to be in and you can
instantly gain access to the internet as
though you're in that country for
example I wanted to go back and watch
the Lord of the Rings movies before
watching the new Lord of the Rings show
and it wasn't available here in the US
so I switched my location to Italy and I
was able to stream all three movies for
free watching Netflix without Pia is
like getting dozens of gifts for your
birthday but you can only open up one
Pia is one of the best services in the
world with over 30 million downloads in
10 years of VPN expertise if you go to
Pia VPN n.com Thrones there will be an
exclusive discount waiting for my
audience only and it is completely
risk-free with Pia's 30-day money-back
guarantee and 24 7 customer service Pia
now has 50 servers and 50 states meaning
that it is the best and fastest VPN in
the US you can now watch any TV events
without blackouts plus Pia is one of the
only vpns to offer P2P sharing now Pia
will also block ads trackers and
malicious websites eia is available for
all platforms including Windows Android
iOS and many many more you can protect
up to 10 devices with your Pia
subscription at the same time Pia is
completely transparent not only is their
VPN code public so that you can take a
look under the hood and examine just how
secure it really is but Pia also has a
no log policy they don't save any logs
so not even Pia can see what you're
doing online when you're connected once
again go to piavpn.com com Thrones today
and get 83 discount for two years plus
four months for free to start protecting
yourself today you don't want to miss
out on this amazing offer thanks again
to Pia VPN for sponsoring today's video
alright now let's have a look at what
was said during Mr Harrington's recent
interview on the Jimmy Fallon show in
this new article it says he isn't giving
anything away when it comes to the
future of his Game of Thrones character
Jon Snow during Friday's episode of The
Tonight Show starring Jimmy Fallon host
Jimmy Fallon asked the actor about the
validity of rumors surrounding an
upcoming sequel series about snow while
smiling and scratching his ear
Harrington kept his response simple
telling Fallon I don't know do you want
to have it although the actor is
remaining silent about the new show even
informing Fallon I can't say anything
about the upcoming series Harrington
noted that there is one reason why he
would do a sequel series and that's to
get more attention he said I don't know
man I'll walk down the street and I get
recognized a little less nowadays and it
kind of hurts my go you know I got a
tally in my head of how few photos I get
asked for in a day Harrington continued
and when it gets below a certain number
I think I'll do a spin-off show that's
when Jimmy Fallon made a joke letting
the fans of Kit Harington know not to
ask him for a photo he said if you do it
for the next few days by Monday we could
have an answer and we could see a Game
of Thrones show right now with Jon Snow
we will do this together now although
they were joking a little bit right here
I do still find it interesting how Mr
Harrington hasn't shut down the rumors
about the new show I think he could
easily say the show will not happen at
all but that's not what he does in fact
what he does say is I can't say anything
about that because HBO doesn't want him
revealing anything just yet another
thing I find very interesting is how he
asked Jimmy Fallon if he wanted this
show that lets me know he is wondering
if the fans are still interested in
watching a series about Jon Snow if you
saw his recent interview during HBO's
first ever fan convention for Game of
Thrones then you would know Harrington
still thinks there is some unfinished
business with Jon Snow there during that
convention Harrington also revealed that
snow was not okay where fans last saw
him at the end of Game of Thrones after
the series finale which saw him killing
Daenerys and being banished to the wall
in the north Harrington said his
character would have felt he got off
lightly he said that the fact that he
goes to the wall is the greatest gift
but also the greatest curse he said he's
got to go back up there with all this
history and live out his life thinking
about how he killed Dany and live out
his life thinking about how Yeager died
in his arms and live out his life
thinking about how he hung Ali and he
said that's that's interesting so I
think where we leave him at the end of
the show there's always this feeling of
like I think we wanted some kind of
little smile that things are okay but
he's not okay added Harrington and I
believe this is what he will want to
explore in the new series
um my question is the fact that your
character Jon Snow he goes through such
a progression throughout the seasons
he's a ward um he goes to war so many
things happen to him
um he finds out that he is you know he's
a Targaryen and then he unfortunately I
told Danny and then he goes you know
they throw him in jail and then he ends
up back on the wall do you ever think
that Jennifer like your character may
have been cheated he kind of goes back
to the you know the rule isn't exactly
the most common place on Earth yeah I
thought that I am yeah
um
I think he I think if you asked him
he thought he would have felt he got off
lightly
he you know at the end of the show when
we find him in that cell
he's preparing to be beheaded
and he wants to be he's done like
the fact he goes to the wall is the
greatest gift to him
and also the great curse
he's going to go back up to the place
with all this history
and live out his life thinking about how
he killed Danny
and live out his life thinking about
Egret dying
and live out his life thinking about how
he hung Ollie
and live out his life thinking about all
of this trauma
and that
that's interesting
so I think that the
when we leave him at the end of the show
there's always this feeling of like
I think we wanted some kind of little
smile things are okay he's not okay
it's not okay
we would see how Jon Snow deals with the
aftermath of everything that has
happened in his life thus far not only
that but I also think something would
happen that would force Jon to go south
again I believe some serious issue would
have to arise driving him to go south
and face it head on now that is
certainly a show I would be interested
in watching not to mention Jon Snow
could also reunite with a lot of his old
friends and enemies there were several
actors from Game of Thrones who have
already said they would love to come
back to Westeros the actors for Arya
Stark Samwell Brienne and a few others
are ready to come back into the Game of
Thrones Universe once again so there are
a few options for the direction of this
show although Mr Harrington still hasn't
confirmed anything himself he has said
enough to let all of us know he's still
thinking about Jon Snow and I know all
of us Game of Thrones fans are as well
as always make sure you subscribe that
way you're up to date whenever any new
information is released regarding the
Jon Snow show or House of the dragon's
second season as well as George R
Martin's The Winds of Winter like I have
said before I will be here making videos
every step of the way also don't forget
to go to the link in the description so
you can start guarding all of your
information today thanks for watching
everyone I hope all of you have a great
day I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
foreign